[Music]
in-depth funded vacation news submitted
by your welcome Sallie Mae executives
are living up on a maori retreat while
the student debt crisis tops 1.6
trillion
i heard about this ships with a baron
they're celebrating their [ __ ] sales
man to do the olympics
I mean AIG was it AIG though is that the
insurance company yeah ah
immediately after the [ __ ] bailout
you know what they did they did on they
did a [ __ ] company trip and spent
mills damn right after the bailout yeah
so more than 100 Sallie Mae employees
took a five-day all-expense-paid trip
courtesy of the company and they some of
them even took their families and they
stayed longer wait so is this alone they
do student loans loans typically don't
they do mortgages and everything to or
just student loans they started to offer
private loans recently but initially
they were doing they were funding the
the federal loans so like through the
government the ones that you have to pay
yeah yeah but then now they've work
they've gone into like private stuff
which is really [ __ ] people over
times ten both of them are the federal
shit's [ __ ] people over just as hard
if not harder really because you have to
pay them you cannot file for bankruptcy
but there's no there's this one woman
who like her story here she ended up
taking out a one hundred and twenty
thousand dollar loan to pay for graduate
school and she was saying that even
after filing for bankruptcy like she
they still coming after her and now the
interest has collected so much to where
she owes three hundred and four thousand
dollar my god got a lawyer to try to
fight it so they're in the middle of
this right now but then Sallie Mae is
saying well that's not our problem
because remember Sallie Mae split up and
now there's Naviance and that's the one
that is responsible for this [ __ ] I
stole them me too you guys had student
loans from
I had a student loan where it was
started off with Sallie Mae and then it
ended as maybe so maybe it BOTS too
sorry they like branched off what I wish
that they did is when it came time to
pay the bar tab they had to call all the
students are all the money and shake
them down just on the phone okay because
they're like look we spent $7,000 on
[ __ ] mai tais what are you doing right
now like send us money right now euros
yeah I know so shitty so low that's what
people should picture people always
picture like well yeah there are
companies going on on vacation but this
money comes from all this predatory
loans right exactly and I mean saying it
that the next recession is the student
loan debt crisis that's probably gonna
be the next thing not the housing it's
gonna start from there and they don't
teach kids financial management at
school by [ __ ] design go take out a
high-risk loan they don't teach you how
to manage your funds at all most people
in America have $2,000 in the bank
account they cannot handle an emergency
past a couple thousand and that's why I
created an emollient academy Jamali and
academy.com you got to go check it out
because i don't want [ __ ] or fast to
be a bunch of [ __ ] losers that don't
know [ __ ] about budgeting that [ __ ] yeah
I'll give you it it's all free anyway
because I don't want people to be
[ __ ] real
I want people to be [ __ ] up in life
and and doing this exactly but that's
more like I'm just gonna play devil's
advocate because that's the whole like
capitalist our mindset though like how
can you how can you find loopholes that
benefit you but here's the thing that's
the worst part about capitalism right
cuz it's like it's like well you can say
pyramid scam is capitalism right but
it's it's it's it's not really creating
value in this world what's ending up
happening is it's kind of like leeching
off of society so they're sucking the
group dry and for me I'm like I don't
know man
loans are great if you know how to use
them but in this case it's kind of
[ __ ] up because you're loaning it out
to people who can't pay it yeah the
reason why things are cheap in America
TV's [ __ ] air conditioning all the
[ __ ] is because somebody somewhere some
[ __ ] is like I want to get rich
selling air conditioners selling TVs
some dishwashers
refrigerators right so but the idea is
that they're in they're like quest for
wealth they're providing a service that
we all want to buy and enough people go
you know what I want to sell that too
and then there's competition and the
drives prices down
that's good capitalism bad capitalism is
predatory loans and then also we're
gonna get Congress and we're gonna make
sure that we don't teach kids anything
about finance like barely at all so
there's a higher chance of them [ __ ]
up so for example it's like this you
know what loan sharking is right or like
you know high interest loans basically
I'm the mob and I'm saying okay I know
you can't [ __ ] pay this but you need
the money I know you desperately need it
because you're gonna need this to live
and probably try to upgrade your life
with my ten thousand dollars but here
you know but I'm gonna charge you 20% on
that [ __ ] and I know you can't [ __ ]
pay it and then I purposely make sure
you [ __ ] up somehow making sure that I
have a higher chance of you not paying
that so you default on that and then I
go here we go a lifetime I'm gonna stack
up that 20% on you non-stop so that's
basically the concept here is the
interest is so [ __ ] high and they try
their best to guarantee that people will
[ __ ] up well it's like they're selling a
lemon right because if you know that
this degree is not gonna be worth
fuck-all right like that's poor job
they're increasing the [ __ ] school
rates to you so it's like you're [ __ ]
in every direction it's like a [ __ ]
catch-22 freeze and it's also they have
a monopoly of it but that is just one of
the like the downsides of capitalism
capitalism you know any that's supposed
to be illegal so you know 92% of the 1.6
trillion dollars in nationwide student
debt is from federal student loans and
only 1.4 percent are from private that's
what I said it's mostly the [ __ ]
federal loans but see what I don't know
I haven't been updated on this specific
thing but when I was in college right
the way that they had loans were
government loans were the best ones
because their interest rate was like 3
[ __ ] percent 4 percent for their
start profiting off of the kids right
but then and then you don't have to pay
your loan until you graduate so that was
fair I thought that was really fair and
if you go into jobs we
our government were there scarce like
teaching and whatever they'll actually
pay an excuse your loan a fort is of
course it's paid by taxpayer money but
there were so many things like that when
did it turn into the [ __ ] monster
that did that it is today because some
of them it's the minute you take the
loan out they expect you to start paying
it since as a student loan because let's
say you're [ __ ] like a like a kid
with the eighty thousand dollar loan
you're you're a student you don't have a
job right how the [ __ ] are you gonna pay
that monthly bill of thousands of
dollars every month when you didn't why
it's kind of stupid on the kid to
[ __ ] do it I don't know why baby a
lot of them don't even have the
education to never have to do it and or
they don't feel like they have the
choice or they get recruited and these
salespeople that are getting treated in
Maui and [ __ ] they're the ones travel
all these people I think you guys right
now are kind of preaching to the choir
because the people who are watching this
definitely understand and have
compassion and I probably see your
perspective so I'm gonna take this the
one step further and ask what do you
guys think are steps that can be taken
towards you know making it more fair and
getting rid of this I think I stopped
funding the [ __ ] of war economy and we
forgive all student loan debt with the
same [ __ ] money well Bernie yes yeah
yeah you're right um wants to take it
from the the trades right what is it
let's take it from the trades like a
dollar from everything from every trade
or whatever I didn't use that to do wipe
out I've heard that yeah that's him in
warrant they both have a very similar
plan I think I think it depends like if
you're in the situation or we're talking
about prevention so I think for me a lot
of people that are [ __ ] their strategy
how it just depends on where they go now
there's actual like government or
nonprofit organizations out there that
help people out with debt and it's all
on my page jamalacademy.com for
with your debt mainly student debt and
things like that and how to [ __ ]
break away from it and yes you can't
clean bankruptcy and all these but
there's ways to do it where you can
actually be excused from it here's what
Bernie all these people [ __ ] up though
we all know that all this [ __ ] is so bad
that all this pervasive crazy lone [ __ ]
is terrible why are they still Haley
doing this [ __ ] still like no there's no
there's no nuts turn off a little asset
there's a lot of there's a CEO but
that's what I'm saying but here's the
here's the sad part we need recessions
so if you think about things in a macro
sense right and this is just my theory
but it is a known fact that reece
recessions are reset buttons for the
economy and it's just the ebb and flow
of things and you can't have constant
ballooning because what ends up
happening is in capitalism there's
overconsumption right so there's gonna
be a diminishing law of return there's
gonna be a point where people are too
fat they're consuming too much they're
gaining too much entertainment they're
building too many homes there's just
gonna be a the balloons got a pop at
will at one point and it always happens
every I think 15 years or some [ __ ] like
that there's a there's a math behind it
we haven't seen one yet so people are
just getting to that point where it's
like I'm getting fat I'm getting fat I'm
getting fat and every time this happens
there's something that balloons it and
you know the recent one was the housing
crisis right people were just buying
homes people that couldn't afford homes
were being like yeah you could have you
yeah [ __ ] your 300 square credit
score zero money down come on dad you
deserve a house I get it you have every
right to have a house it's the American
dream I don't give a [ __ ] if you don't
even have a minimum wage job you have
the right to own a house if I get a
6-feet every time you put your name any
people are like yeah yeah I want a house
I deserve a house right same [ __ ] with
the school [ __ ] you deserve to be
educated you gotta upgrade yourself
people are just being told that [ __ ] and
then they're given all this money and
then the sales guy don't give a [ __ ] cuz
he's like I made my money right so then
they inflate inflate they and then they
blow up this economy and then boom it's
gonna pop and it's gonna be a huge reset
and it's gonna continue we're gonna
figure out they're gonna figure out new
ways to inflate and boom and I think
that is kind of constructed that's the
conspiracy side of me or it's either
constructed or its let unaccounted for
because they know that it's
to happen and so many who are making so
much money they don't give a [ __ ]
because think about how many industries
are making so much money from the
students colleges alone billions of
money you know billions even just the
the student exchange I heard just China
alone every year they bring in like 15
billion to the states from their
exchange student program Chinese money
only China so that's not talking about
the Middle East yeah Europe all the
millionaire's coming from there
dude it's a lot of money like trillions
of dollars so how can you stop that
[Music]